I'm getting ready to submit a second cheek swab for supplement recommendations.
How does one know what it might be a good time to do a rife update?
But almost a year, but faithfully using it, but doing well, but my PSA is recently going up.
So it depends on the cancer. So for prostate cancer, really the only time you need to do a rife
update for prostate cancer is if there's metastasis. So if there's no metastasis with prostate cancer,
with other cancers, it depends. If the person's getting worse, it's good to check that rife
update. They don't check and see if you need a rife update. They don't do it. So a lot of you
send in your cheek swab forms and you check general recommendations. You might make some notes and you
might check rife update too and you don't need a rife update. So we don't charge you for a rife
update. So you could check that and I'll check most likely the answers. No, you won't need it.